that was a really strange circumstance I
was actually in London and everyone else
was in Los Angeles and I got sent these
scripts anyway I read the first script
and I was like yeah yeah and they were
like will you stay up uh a little bit
later at this point it was getting kind
of late in London uh to talk to Neil
druckman the creator of the video game
stay up for that Zoom We All Fall in
Love and then at that point it's it's
really late I've got to get up in the
morning uh I take an Ambien yeah to go
to sleep just in case I I I'm they've
got my adrenaline kind of going in my
anti my hopes up I bet I get a call and
I get told that I got the job after I
took the Ambien
and so I was excited I guess but I
didn't remember
I woke up in the morning and the first
thing that occurred to me was like oh
man
I really want that job
I'm in London there in L.A I'm gonna
wait by the phone I'm gonna be longing
and I was like oh congratulations so
happy for you when I looked at my phone
I was like oh yeah I got the job